Générique
...
-Bonjour à tous !
Bienvenue dans
"Politiques à tables !",
nous sommes ensemble
pendant une heure
pour parler cuisine,
alimentation,
agriculture,
et un peu politique.
Cette semaine,
on reçoit
Emmanuelle Jary.
-Bonjour.
-Merci d'être venue.
Avec moi,
pour présenter,
Jean-Pierre Montanay.
-Bonjour à vous !
-Bonjour.
-Vous êtes critique
gastronomique,
version 2.0.
On peut vous suivre
depuis 2016,
sur votre chaîne YouTube.
On vous voit généralement
attablée dans un restaurant,
un bistrot...
C'est pas du 4 étoiles.
C'est simple et authentique.
Vous commentez les plats.
Vous discutez avec le chef.
Plus qu'une critique,
c'est une tranche de vie.
Vous avez décliné ce concept
en livres et en trimestriel.
Un magazine,
qui s'appelle
C'est meilleur
quand c'est bon.
Vous avez lancé
cette aventure
avec votre mari,
Mathieu Pansard,
dont on ne connaît
que la voix.
Ca décolle en 2019
avec une vidéo
à 40 millions de vues.
Carton assuré.
On vous arrête
dans la rue, vous,
la femme de presse écrite,
qui a étudié 10 ans
l'ethnologie de la cuisine.
Quand vous nous avez donné
votre menu,
on a été obligés
avec Jean-Pierre
d'ouvrir une encyclopédie.
-Une soupe oubliée
au drôle de nom,
une soupe châtrée,
on en parlera,
et en dessert,
mousse au chocolat.
-Les influenceurs food font
la pluie et le beau temps
sur la gastronomie.
Faut-il suivre leur avis ?
Précisions.
-Amateurs de cuisses de grenouilles
à la persillade, attention !
Le reporte à venir pourrait
vous en dégoûter.
-Allez, on passe à table.
Tout de suite,
Cuisine et confidences.
-D'abord, Emmanuelle Jarry,
en recevant
une critique gastronomique
dont le slogan est
"C'est meilleur quand c'est bon",
on était plutôt rassurés
sur votre choix culinaire du jour.
Bon, c'est meilleur
que quelconque.
Notre seul doute se résumait
à une question emberlificotée :
ce sera seulement bon
ou meilleur que bon ?
Pour les indices, je me suis
plongé dans votre livre.
C'est le numéro 3
de votre revue
daté de décembre 2023,
qui m'a permis d'y voir
clair avec des recettes
d'hiver oubliées
que vous avez exhumées,
comme la pintade farcie
et ses marrons,
ou les Ouyettes de Langres !
Vous connaissez, Brigitte ?
-Pas du tout.
-Des chaussons
farcis au canard confit.
Vous avez
souhaité réchauffer
nos corps et nos âmes
avec une soupe
de montagne
au fromage,
la soupe châtrée.
Adjectif curieux
qui désigne d'ordinaire
plutôt un chaperon
plutôt qu'une soupe confectionnée
à partir de restes.
De votre propre aveu,
vous n'avez jamais goûté.
Mais ça vous fait
terriblement envie.
L'occasion fait le larron.
En espérant
que vous allez
nous dire comme
une enfant gourmande :
"C'est beaucoup meilleur."
-Oui, ça, c'est important,
pour moi, ces recettes.
Pourquoi
je les ai pas goûtées ?
C'est des recettes
qu'on ne connaît pas.
Pour cette revue
dont on parlait,
je travaille avec
des stylistes culinaires,
avec des photographes
et je leur demande
ce travail.
J'ai une collection de livres
de cuisine depuis 20 ans.
Elles aussi.
On a exhumé
des recettes...
Mon idée n'est pas,
comme je disais...
Dans la revue numéro 2,
une recette m'a
un peu traumatisée.
Une quiche au saumon
et aux poireaux.
-Un petit peu banal.
-Et surtout,
on n'a pas besoin...
C'est une super recette
mais on n'a pas besoin de nous,
en fait, pour la donner...
-Ce sont des recettes
régionales, oubliées.
Ou on les consomme
très localement ?
Je ne les connaissais pas.
-C'est possible...
Je pense que dans
certaines familles,
on les fait encore,
mais pour avoir parcouru
la France et filmé
des restaurants
et fait des reportages,
je n'ai jamais mangé ça
dans des restaurants.
Voilà.
Il y a une uniformisation
des goûts, en France.
Du fait de la restauration.
Les chefs cuisinent
les mêmes choses.
A "C'est meilleur quand c'est bon",
je voulais faire ce que j'aime,
aller retrouver
des recettes qu'on ne fait plus,
mais qui partent d'une région.
-Comme les vieux légumes
qu'on exhume.
-C'est ça !
En fait,
oui et non.
Parce que les vieux légumes,
c'est des produits.
Quand je fais mes reportages,
je demande s'ils font
une cuisine locale.
On me dit oui.
Pour moi,
une cuisine locale,
c'est pas acheter
les produits
à 5 kilomètres.
Ca tombe sous le sens
d'acheter local...
Ce qui est important
pour la cuisine locale,
c'est de cuisiner à Marseille,
marseillais,
en Anjou,
une cuisine angevine,
et en Alsace,
une cuisine alsacienne.
Les Marseillais ont
une culture culinaire préservée,
le Pays basque aussi.
L'Alsace, beaucoup.
-Nice.
Il y a pas mal de régions...
-Je cite toujours l'Anjou.
Les pauvres
doivent se dire...
-"Pourquoi ?"
-J'y ai fait
un reportage !
Impossible de trouver
une recette angevine.
Donc, j'ai demandé,
avec les personnes,
on est une vingtaine,
notamment
les stylistes culinaires :
"Trouvez-moi des recettes
que je ne connais pas."
J'avais jamais goûté.
-Goûtez-la
et dites-nous
si vous la trouvez...
Si vous la trouvez bonne.
Et puis, pendant ce temps,
trois choses à savoir.
-Comme on la connaît pas,
cette rubrique peut servir
à quelque chose.
La littérature culinaire
est peu prolixe à ce sujet.
Cette recette est restée
confinée à un territoire
autour du village
de Morillon.
Ceux qui font du ski
le connaissent.
Morillon revendique
la paternité
de cette soupe.
Pour la confectionner,
il faut superposer
une couche de pain sec,
une couche de fromage,
vous remplissez
votre soupière.
Et à la fin,
vous arrosez le tout
avec une soupe aux oignons.
Une soupe aux oignons filtrée,
donc, sans les oignons.
Vous faites cuire ça
au four,
plus d'une heure,
à 180 degrés.
La soupe va ainsi
gratiner
et le fromage
va durcir,
voilà pourquoi
il faut la châtrer.
Jonathan,
qui l'a faite,
l'a découpée,
avec un couteau.
Il faut l'émasculer !
Les puristes,
d'ailleurs,
la savourent
avec une fourchette.
Après une soupe châtrée,
c'est l'appétit
qui est coupé !
C'est une soupe d'hiver
qu'on mange
aussi le 21 août.
-L'été ?
-A la Saint-Christophe.
-Ca n'a rien
d'une soupe.
-Non, parce que...
Les puristes la mangent
à la fourchette.
Le pain a absorbé tout le jus
de la soupe versée dessus.
Est-elle un peu sèche ?
Je n'en sais rien.
Mais c'est bon
et gourmand.
-C'est bon ?
-J'aime beaucoup.
Il y a du fromage fondu
et du pain...
C'est la cuisine
que j'aime beaucoup,
un peu paysanne,
dans laquelle
on utilise les restes.
On voit bien que
c'est une recette ancienne.
On imagine
des restes de croûtes,
à un moment donné,
des restes de pain
dur comme du béton.
On le mouille,
avec des oignons,
ça parfume...
-C'est économique.
-Et bah, en fait,
après une journée de ski,
on est contents
de manger ça.
-Ca cale bien.
-Je trouve ça dommage,
l'uniformisation
des goûts et de se dire
qu'on va trouver
du foie gras...
On en trouve partout.
Si vous êtes sur la Côte d'Azur,
vous voulez pas manger ça.
Et vous...
Donc...
Les recettes ont pas été
inventées pour rien.
Désolée pour les restaurateurs.
Tout le monde fait pas ça
mais ceux qui proposent
la même chose,
du foie gras,
de la souris d'agneau...
Je sais plus...
-Vous partez en guerre
contre des petits restos,
contre les bistrots...
La cuisine de bistrot,
c'est un peu
toujours la même.
-Je pars en guerre
contre la bistronomie.
Mais il en faut aussi.
Ca a permis d'apporter
la haute cuisine
à un prix moindre
car il y avait pas
le service
de la haute
gastronomie
et ça a permis
d'apporter...
-De la démocratiser.
-Voilà.
Exactement.
Il faut pas...
On parle toujours du fast food
pour l'uniformisation du goût,
mais je pense qu'il y a aussi
les chefs qui, à un moment,
ont voulu tous faire
la même chose,
car il y a des modes,
et que la mode,
c'est appauvrir la cuisine.
-Vous leur demandez
d'être créatif ?
-Oui !
Si vous êtes dans une région...
Vous pouvez être créatif
et c'est super !
Tout le monde peut pas être
un chef créatif.
Prendre
ce que les siècles ont laissé,
c'est bien aussi.
Mais, euh...
-Et cultiver
les produits du terroir.
-Ca paraît évident.
C'est complètement absurde
d'aller chercher
des produits dans le nord,
si on habite à Menton.
-C'est dur pour la bistronomie.
Vous trouvez ça uniforme
mais on lui reprochait aussi
d'être trop inventive,
créative pour être créative,
avec des slashs
anchois-pamplemousse,
kiw-buratta...
Il y a eu plein
de créations.
Elle s'est pas uniformisée.
La bistronomie,
elle propose un éventail
de plats et de recettes.
-Je trouve qu'en fait
tout le monde
n'a pas la capacité
d'être un chef créatif.
La créativité des grands chefs...
Il y en a, des chefs français,
c'est ce qui fait notre cuisine...
Tout le monde ne peut pas...
Il y a l'artisanat,
dans la peinture,
et les grands maîtres
de la peinture.
En cuisine,
c'est pareil.
La bistronomie,
les slashs, pour moi,
c'est pas de la création,
c'est...
De l'originalité
pour être original.
Je résume toujours
la bistronomie à...
Euh...
Les navets... Non !
Les betteraves Chioggia
coupées à la mandoline,
avec de l'huile
de noisette.
C'est la mauvaise bistronomie.
-La caricature
de la bistronomie.
-Matthieu Garrel, au Bélisaire,
à Paris, dans le 15e,
est un chef qui fait une très,
très grande bistronomie.
J'applaudis des deux mains.
J'aime pas ces personnes
qui n'ont pas
forcément
le talent pour.
Faites un boeuf bourguignon,
on sera contents.
On m'avait parlé d'un sondage.
Un cabinet de sondage m'a dit,
c'est des chiffres
approximatifs,
mais 70 %
des Français
ne vont que deux fois par an
au restaurant.
Et y dépensent
17 euros ou moins.
Vous voyez ce que je veux dire ?
Il faut...
La bistronomie est
déjà un grand moment.
Dépenser 40 euros
à table, etc.
-Il faut quelque chose
d'exceptionnel.
-C'est parisien.
-Exactement.
Moi, je m'attarde souvent
dans des petites tables, oui,
car je veux m'adresser
au plus grand nombre !
Je suis pas contre...
J'ai filmé un étoilé Michelin.
-Vous êtes pas très étoilés.
On les connaît bien mieux,
que la cuisine du terroir,
ou les bistrots...
-Exactement !
Ils ont déjà beaucoup de...
Ils sont déjà
très médiatiques.
Ils ont pas besoin de nous
pour la publicité.
Il y a beaucoup de gens
qui ne vont jamais
dans un étoilé de leur vie,
ou une fois ou deux.
-Vous regardez le prix
du restaurant
avant ?
"Je reste à moins
de 20 euros" ?
-Non, je regarde le rapport
qualité-prix.
Il y a des restaurants
super à 12 euros.
A 40, ce serait pas bien
mais à 12 euros,
c'est formidable !
Et l'étoilé que j'ai filmé,
la Réserve Rimbaud,
à Montpellier,
il propose un menu à 45 euros
le midi...
Dans ce cadre...
-Pas cher.
-C'est pas cher du tout.
Je lui ai demandé
comme il faisait entrée,
plat, dessert,
avec l'argenterie,
le service...
A Paris, la veille,
j'avais
mangé un plat
à 45 euros.
-A Paris !
Sans doute que les loyers...
-Peut-être.
Il y a ces considérations.
-Il équilibre...
-Il a dit que c'était
peut-être
un menu d'appel,
mais que pour faire
des prix pas chers,
il fallait
cuisiner.
Je l'ai dit en interview,
quand on n'a pas d'argent,
la solution est de cuisiner.
Un bon produit, les chefs le disent,
on n'a pas besoin de le cuisiner.
Mais des pommes de terre,
pour bluffer quelqu'un...
-Il faut s'améliorer.
-Des bonnes
pommes de terre
avec un peu de beurre
ou de l'huile d'olive...
-Guy Savoy m'a épatée
quand j'avais 20 ans.
Ca m'a donné envie
de faire ce métier...
J'avais été invitée chez Guy Savoy
pour mes 20 ans.
J'avais mangé une soupe
de lentilles à la truffe.
-Elle est très connue !
-A la truffe !
-Ce que je veux dire...
Pour arriver à épater
quelqu'un à ce prix-là,
il faut beaucoup
travailler
les lentilles.
-Vous êtes pas
très étoilés,
mais votre révélation,
vous l'avez dans un étoilé.
Chez Georges Blanc.
-Je venais d'avoir le bac.
Donc, voilà...
Chez Georges Blanc,
à Vonnas.
Je suis originaire
de la Bresse,
du département de l'Ain.
Je dis la Bresse,
car je suis née
à Bourg-en-Bresse.
Mon père m'a promis un étoilé
en échange d'une mention au bac.
J'ai eu une mention.
J'ai choisi...
Enfin, il y avait
une carte.
Rires
Il m'avait dit :
"Je t'offre un 3 étoiles !"
Georges Blanc,
j'en avais entendu parler.
Et en fait,
je m'attendais à manger
quelque chose d'incroyable,
et ce qui m'a bluffée,
dans son restaurant,
c'est le service.
Ca a fait qu'après,
j'ai fait de l'ethnologie
de la cuisine
pour comprendre ce que c'était,
que ce service.
Je ne soupçonnais pas...
Les cloches qui se soulèvent,
le ballet des serveurs,
qui se regardaient,
et ils soulevaient
les cloches...
-Une mise en scène.
-Ouais. Exactement.
Cette mise en scène,
j'ai senti
qu'il y avait autre chose
derrière, et donc...
Je voulais faire
une école hotellière
mais je voulais pas
faire de la compta.
J'ai commencé
les études
d'ethnologie...
-C'est quoi ?
Dites-nous en plus.
-L'ethnologie travaille
sur les différentes cultures
dans le monde.
Elle étudie les cultures.
La façon dont on mange
est une des façons de vivre.
On peut travailler
sur les systèmes
de parenté
mais aussi
comment mangent les Papous
en Nouvelle-Guinée.
J'ai décidé de réfléchir
à comment mangent les Français
de la haute bourgeoisie.
Et donc...
Certains professeurs m'ont dit
que c'était pas ethnologique
mais j'ai trouvé
ma directrice de thèse,
qui a dit
que tout
était intéressant.
Effectivement,
ce que j'ai découvert
les travaux
de Norbert Elias,
un sociologue,
historien,
des manières de table,
entre autres,
c'est que le rituel
du grand restaurant
est emprunté
à l'étiquette de la cour
à l'époque de Louis XIV
à Versailles.
C'était...
Un...
Un outil de pouvoir
pour le roi sur sa cour.
Et en fait,
chaque table,
c'est une petite cour...
C'était mon postulat.
J'ai commencé une thèse
mais je l'ai pas soutenue.
C'était en maîtrise.
Chaque table est
une petit cour
reconstitué.
Et les...
Les serveurs sont...
Le client est le roi.
Les serveurs
le disent, d'ailleurs.
Ma directrice de thèse
me dit de prendre ça
au pied de la lettre
et de comparer.
On retrouve énormément
dans les interactions...
Entre le client
et le serveur...
Des usages
de l'étiquette.
-Vous avez travaillé un an
chez Lucas Carton,
vous avez retrouvé ça ?
Le client était roi ?
Ca respectait ça ?
-Ouais.
On ne contredisait
jamais le client.
Lors d'une prise
de commande,
j'enregistrais discrètement
avec un petit dictaphone.
Une table commande
un poisson et une viande.
Arrivent
Un convive dit :
"On a commandé 2 poissons."
Le maître d'hôtel dit :
"Non, madame..."
Mais si madame vous dit
qu'elle a commandé un poisson,
c'est que c'est le cas.
On ramène tout.
Panique en cuisine, il faut
que ça sorte très rapidement.
On offre le champagne
aux clients
pour faire passer
la pilule.
Quand on a dérushé,
j'ai entendu.
On m'a dit :
"Le client a raison."
-Le client est pas roi,
il est chiant.
Rires
-C'est pour vous dire
jusqu'où ça allait.
On ne contredisait jamais
Louis XIV
en effet.
Il y avait énormément
de choses comme ça.
Il y avait d'autres choses
incroyables.
Il fallait reconnaître.
Une fois qu'il s'étaient annoncés.
Il y avait
une communication parallèle
que le client voyait pas.
Tout ce qu'il avait dit,
il fallait que ce soit
acquis.
Donc, si monsieur Dupont
arrivait, et qu'il allait
dans un petit salon,
on faisait
passer le message
que c'était lui.
Arrivé à l'étage :
"Bonjour, M. Dupont."
Comme le roi,
on le reconnaissait aussi.
Une hiérarchie intéressante.
-La cuisine et le fait de se nourrir
sont universels.
Avez-vous trouvé selon
des peuples, des ethnies,
des différences d'appréhension
de cette façon de consommer,
de cette façon de cuisiner ?
-Ah oui.
Ah bah oui, bien sûr.
D'abord, les dégoûts.
Il n'y a pas plus compliqué
que de s'investir
dans la cuisine
de quelqu'un d'autre.
En tant que journaliste,
j'ai fait un reportage
en Mauritanie
et on m'a servi
un couscous
de bosses de chameau.
Et la bosse de chameau,
c'est très gras.
Ca sent très fort.
Ca sent un peu les pieds.
Rires
Pour donner cette...
Une odeur rance...
-Vous l'avez mangée ?
-Je l'ai mangée, par...
Par correction.
-Professionnelle.
-Il fallait manger avec la main.
Je déteste, j'ai pas l'habitude.
-Dans plein de pays,
on fait ça.
-On était chez des nomades,
on avait passé 2 jours
sous la tente.
Ils ont préparé la semoule.
Il y avait du sable
dedans car on était
dans le désert.
Le sable se mélangeait !
Ils le mangent comme ça.
Avec la main,
on fait une boulette.
Ca tombait.
Je trouvais ça dégoûtant.
La personne
qui m'accompagnait
qui était un Mauritanien
du désert me disait :
"Il faut t'habituer,
ce sont nos traditions."
Je le faisais.
Quand on est retournés
dans la ville à côté,
on a mangé un poulet rôti
comme ça,
avec des pommes de terre,
il n'a pas aimé.
Je lui ai dit :
"Tu vois ?"
Il m'a dit que
c'était pas sa culture.
"De la même manière
que je l'ai fait
"car tu m'as reçue,
"toi aussi..."
-"Tu dois t'adapter."
-C'est la chose
la plus compliquée
d'aller manger...
On est allés...
Avec un photographe,
on est allés manger en...
A Bornéo.
On nous a servi du serpent,
des oeufs de serpent,
c'était compliqué.
Il a fallu le manger.
-Il y a une appréhension.
-Il y a un dégoût.
-Les insectes,
on a une appréhension
mais on en mangera.
-Ca ne prend pas alors que c'est
la solution pour les protéines !
-C'est des plats de niche.
J'ai mangé du serpent
au Vietnam.
Il y a aussi
une mondialisation
de la cuisine.
On mange la même chose.
Pas la même chose,
mais quand même.
Il y a...
-C'est vrai.
-Les cuisines
étrangères exotiques
ont du succès dans
les pays occidentaux, etc.
-Bah...
Oui.
Dans nos pays à nous,
mais je veux dire,
pour avoir beaucoup
voyagé...
Dès qu'on sort
des restaurants occidentaux...
L'Occident s'exporte...
-La pizza,
ou le riz cantonnais,
qui s'exporte aussi !
-Honnêtement,
si on s'enfonce un peu
dans les campagnes,
en voyageant,
j'ai découvert
des choses.
Au Cambodge, on m'a servi
des tarentules frites.
Je suis arachnophobe.
Sucer
des pattes de tarentule...
-Les méduses en Chine.
Pas évident.
-J'y arrive davantage.
Mais c'est pas
forcément évident.
Et les Anglais qui
arrivent pas à manger
des lapins
ou des grenouilles.
Enfin...
-Et vous,
votre culture culinaire,
elle vient d'où ?
On mangeait quoi,
chez vous, à table,
quand vous étiez
enfant ?
-Bah,
je viens de la Bresse,
on mangeait des volailles.
Le poulet du dimanche.
Comme beaucoup de Français.
Mes deux grands-mères,
paternelle et maternelle,
habitaient
au même village
et elles cuisinaient
beaucoup, beaucoup !
-Cuisine simple ?
-Il y avait les deux.
Il y avait la cuisine du dimanche.
Un civet de lièvre,
ça prenait 4 jours.
Pour des repas de fête.
Et puis aussi des recettes
tout à fait simples.
Je sais pas...
Une viande grillée...
On mangeait toujours
les légumes avant
et ensuite la viande.
-Pas en même temps et dans ce sens ?
-C'est ça.
Il y a des traditions régionales.
On mange souvent la salade
en début de repas.
-Il y en a qui
la mangent au fromage.
-Quand je suis arrivée à Paris,
c'était avec le fromage.
-Une hérésie.
-J'aime pas ça.
J'aime la manger
en entrée.
D'abord les légumes
et ensuite la viande.
Avec la salade.
Donc, euh...
On passait du temps
en cuisine.
à en parler.
-Et vous cuisinez,
d'ailleurs ?
-Oui, j'aime beaucoup.
De moins en moins,
en vieillissant.
Mais à 20 ans, je cuisinais
des repas incroyables,
et les gens de la fac venaient
et trouvaient ça génial.
-Quel genre...
Quel genre de plats ?
-Par exemple,
j'ai commencé...
Déjà des plats
traditionnels.
Je faisais des blanquettes,
des osso-buco,
j'adorais ça.
Je faisais des plats mijotés.
Je prenais de la bonne viande
alors que j'avais pas
tellement d'argent.
Mais je mettais tout là-dedans.
Plus le temps passe,
moins j'aime cuisiner.
Ouais, enfin...
Plus je cuisine...
-Ca vous inspire,
vos escapades gourmandes ?
-Oui mais je suis tellement
dans la cuisine que...
-Trop de bouffe tue la bouffe.
-Exactement.
Je suis tellement au restaurant...
Etudiante,
j'y allais pas beaucoup.
On mangeait à la maison.
Aujourd'hui, j'en fais
plusieurs centaines par an.
Quand je rentre
chez moi...
On me demande
comment je garde la ligne.
Je mange que quand
je suis filmée.
-Ca, ça marche.
Alors...
Pour accompagner ce plat,
vous avez proposé
un bourgogne.
C'est un AOC
Bourgogne aligoté.
Des départements comme l'Yonne,
la Côte-d'Or, la Saône-et-Loire,
et le Rhône,
les 4 départements
où on peut trouver
ce cépage-là.
Ca descend
du pinot noir.
C'est un millésime 2022.
Ses caractéristiques :
arômes de pêche, d'abricot,
de fleurs blanches.
Une attaque assez fraîche
et une puissance minérale
assez typique du terroir.
Pourquoi vous avez choisi
ce vin-là ?
-J'ai eu un coup de foudre.
Il est pas cher.
Moins de 10 euros la bouteille.
C'est intéressant...
-C'est vrai ?
-Un tout petit plus,
mais c'est autour.
-Je l'ai acheté à 9 euros
dans la boutique
où je l'ai acheté.
De l'aligoté,
on en trouve de moins en moins.
C'est avec ça
qu'on faisait le kir.
Le vrai kir.
J'adore la Bourgogne.
J'adore toute l'histoire
du cassis,
de ce fruit...
J'adore tout
ce qui me rappelle
une région.
On s'arrêtait
toujours en Bourgogne
quand on achetait
du vin avec mon père.
C'est des vrais souvenirs.
Quand je suis tombée
sur ce vin...
On fait des kirs avec
n'importe quel vin blanc
alors que moi,
j'aime respecter la tradition.
Et euh... Donc, voilà,
je l'ai beaucoup aimé.
Il est très agréable
à boire, facile.
J'aime beaucoup ce vin.
Bon rapport qualité-prix.
Je l'ai mis en avant.
-Ca se marie bien
avec le fromage :
comté, chèvre...
Et donc avec cette soupe.
-Ouais.
On peut le boire avec ça
et n'hésitez pas,
à l'apéritif,
avec, euh...
Il y a une...
De la même famille,
un producteur de crème de cassis
a été un énorme coup de foudre
dans nos vidéos.
On a l'impression
de plonger
dans un grain de cassis.
Il faut...
-Un kir.
-J'allais dire,
un peu de liquide avec...
C'est ma première soupe solide.
Rires
Avec un couteau !
Donc, peut-être qu'il faut
verser un peu de vin
dans la soupe.
-On va voir
si vous êtes incollable.
C'est le Quiz.
-Vous adorez les grenouilles.
Surtout celles...
On dit de "la Dombes"
ou "des Dombes" ?
J'habitais pas loin...
-On dit "la" Dombes.
Avec le "S",
souvent, on dit "des".
Je viens de Villars-les-Dombes,
mais c'est "la Dombes".
-Celles de la Dombes,
où habitaient vos grands-parents.
Sauriez-vous
nous dire
si ces affirmations
les concernant
sont vraies ou fausses ?
Il lit la première affirmation.
...
14e siècle !
L'historienne...
-Oui, je dirais oui.
-Oui ? Bravo !
-Bravo !
Il lit la 2e affirmation.
..
-Je dirais non.
-C'est celle du Jura !
Dans les Dombes...
Dans la Dombes,
c'est la verte,
la rana esculenta.
Il lit la 3e affirmation.
...
-C'est possible.
-Vrai.
Il lit la 3e affirmation.
...
-Oui.
-Faux !
L'arrêté qui les protège
est plus ancien.
Il date de 1980.
Donc, on peut pêcher
des grenouilles pour...
Son confort personnel.
-Son plaisir.
Je l'ai fait.
-On peut pas les vendre
pour soutenir
l'espèce
qui était en voie
de disparition.
On verra,
tout à l'heure,
un reportage édifiant.
Après la Yougoslavie,
la plupart de nos grenouilles
viennent d'Asie.
Surtout d'Indonésie.
-3 bonnes réponses.
C'est déjà très bien.
Deuxième quiz.
Vous avez découvert l'univers
de la gastronomie
chez Georges Blanc.
A Vonnas ?
"Vonnasse" ?
-Vonnas.
-Sauriez-vous nous dire
si ces affirmations sont
vraies ou fausses ?
Elle lit la première affirmation.
...
-Oui.
-Faux. C'est la Mère Bourgeois,
et pas la Mère Bernard.
-Ah !
Je pensais que c'était
si elle faisait partie...
Si elle faisait partie
des Mères lyonnaises !
-Non, c'était les noms.
-Piège !
Il y a des pièges
de temps en temps.
J'étais obligé !
Autrement,
c'est trop facile.
-La Mère Blanc est désignée
meilleure cuisinière du monde
en 1933 ?
-C'est sur la date que
vous me posez la question.
Elle a 2 étoiles en 1933
au guide Michelin.
Curnonsky l'a désignée
meilleure cuisinière
du monde...
Est-ce en 33 ?
Euh...
Non. Pas en 33 ?
-Si !
Rires
Elle lit la troisième affirmation.
...
On parle de la date, 1978.
-On est sur la date.
-Oh là là...
Euh...
Vraiment au pif, oui.
-Non !
Rires
-Je crois
qu'il reprend
le restaurant en 78,
et il attend
quelques années.
Curnonsky,
c'était plus dur que la date !
-33, elle a eu ses 2 étoiles.
C'est l'année où les Mères...
La Mère Brazier
a eu 3 étoiles.
-Dernière question.
-Sa spécialité
était la quenelle
de sandre en viennoise.
Vrai ou faux ?
-Non, je dirais non.
-Faux, effectivement.
Eclaté de homard
au vin jaune,
fines ravioles à l'oseille.
-Vous vous souvenez
de ce que vous y avez mangé ?
-Oui.
Un méli-mélo au citron confit.
Un sandre au savagnin.
Un omble chevalier.
-C'est un poisson
d'eau douce ?
-Tout à fait.
Je connaissais rien de tout ça.
Je savais pas que le savagnin,
c'était un cépage,
ou que l'omble chevalier
était un poisson.
Un poisson est arrivé...
J'ai pas osé dire
que j'avais pas commandé ça.
-Vous vous souvenez
du menu de vos 18 ans ?
-C'est bon signe.
Quand on se souvient
du menu du restaurant...
Dans les grands restaurants,
comme les blagues,
on s'en souvient plus !
-Et une soupe au sot-l'y-laisse.
Je ne savais pas
ce que c'était
ou comment ça s'écrivait.
Ca a été une telle sidération,
ce moment,
que...
-C'est souvent à table
que se racontent
les meilleurs histoires...
La brève de comptoir.
Emmanuelle Jarry,
on vous a demandé
de vous souvenir
d'une anecdote
autour d'un repas.
Est-ce qu'il y a
un souvenir que vous avez
à raconter ?
-On a eu un tournage très marquant,
"Chez Erwan",
le restaurateur dans les Yvelines,
qui nous a fait connaître.
On a fait tant de vues.
-40 millions.
-Tout à fait.
-C'est énorme !
-Oui, c'est assez fou.
-C'est pas mal.
-On est suivis
sur les réseaux,
ça part à l'étranger.
Des personnes l'ont vu
en Argentine.
On m'a souvent demandé
pourquoi cette vidéo-là.
Lui, c'est un personnage.
Il se trouve que dans cette vidéo,
j'ai eu une petite émotion
que je n'ai pas réussi à cacher,
On parlait de mes grands-parents,
ça m'a rappelé les repas
chez mes grands-parents
ou quand on allait
à la petite auberge.
J'ai eu les yeux un peu brillants.
Mathieu Pansard, qui filme,
l'a vu,
il en a parlé,
et ça a fait couler une larme.
J'avais refusé de garder ça
au montage,
parce que ça me gênait,
c'était quelque chose de personnel.
Mathieu m'a convaincue de la garder,
à raison,
parce que ça a participé
à diffuser
cette vidéo.
C'est ce qui caractérise...
On me demande pourquoi nos vidéos
marchent. Mathieu m'a dit :
"Sois sincère.
"Dis ce que tu penses."
Donc on prépare rien,
et quand je suis devant un plat,
je suis comme avec vous,
et en fait...
Cette larme le prouve,
en fait.
J'ai essayé de la cacher
quand elle a coulé
et on voit le geste.
-Et a ça fonctionné.
-Ca veut dire que l'émotion
est très liée à la table,
à ce qu'on mange, au souvenir
de ce que l'on mange.
C'est intéressant.
-Complètement.
-C'est une émotion.
-C'est ça.
-C'est ce qui a fait le succès
de la vidéo.
-Je crois que oui.
Des gens s'y sont reconnus.
On a tous ressenti ça,
Proust le premier.
Quand j'ai lu le passage
de la madeleine à 15 ans,
c'était extraordinaire.
Quand quelque chose nous percute
les papilles, ou une odeur,
ça nous transporte.
C'est plus qu'un souvenir,
on revit l'instant.
C'est ce qu'il décrit bien.
Je le dis moins bien que Proust.
Mais les gens se sont
reconnus
là-dedans,
parce qu'on a déjà tous eu,
si on boit un verre en plus,
une émotion à table.
On ne guérit jamais
de son enfance,
c'était un peu ça.
-Aujourd'hui,
vous êtes critique
et sur les réseaux sociaux,
on en trouve beaucoup,
et des influenceurs.
Quelle différence ?
Peut-on croire leur avis ?
Le dessous des plats.
La cuisine, grande star
des réseaux sociaux.
Les vidéos des influenceurs
font parfois des millions
de vues.
Les restaurateurs veulent
une chronique
pour augmenter leur clientèle.
Tout est fait pour rendre
l'offre alléchante.
Clément Perrouault nous en parle.
-Ils vous font saliver
en ligne et, accessoirement,
consommer.
-Pour les amateurs de frangipane,
il vous fait celle-ci.
-Ils partagent leurs recettes,
bons plans restos,
voyages culinaires,
le tout
dans une ambiance ultra positive.
-C'est une dinguerie.
-On les appelle
les influenceurs food,
mais s'ils préfèrent le terme
de créateurs.
Parmi les comptes les plus suivis,
celui d'Alexis Thiebaut,
baptisé "Le Paris d'Alexis",
315 000 abonnés.
Il est dans un resto parisien
qu'il vient faire découvrir.
-Pour l'entrée, on est
sur un mélange sucré-salé
hyper équilibré.
La cecina est extrêmement fine,
limite elle fond sur la langue.
-Micro sur le col
et smartphone
à la main, Alexis connaît par coeur
les recettes
pour faire du clic.
-Il faut capter
l'attention
dans les 5 premières secondes.
Et encore, c'est plutôt
les 3 premières,
il faut être percutant
dès le début.
-Ses vidéos tournent souvent
autour de 200 00 vues,
et dépasse souvent le million.
Pour les restaurateurs,
elles constituent
une formidable publicité.
Le chef du restaurant,
ancien candidat
de l'émission "Top chef",
en est bien conscient.
-Dès l'instant
où ils jettent un hameçon,
ils ne pêchent pas un poisson,
ils ont tout un filet derrière,
ils attrapent les personnes prêtes
à regarder ce contenu.
-Si Alexis est toujours invité
par les restaurants,
la plupart de ses vidéos
ne donne pas lieu
à une rémunération.
Ses revenus viennent de contenus
publicitaires spécifiques
commandés par des marques.
On appelle cela des collabs'.
Si les grosses écuries
de l'alimentaire restent
le coeur de ce marché,
de petits restaurants commencent
également à ouvrir leur portefeuille
pour profiter de ces réseaux,
comme cet établissement parisien
au pied de la butte Montmartre.
Sébastien Cardinal,
qui tient un compte
spécialisé dans la cuisine végane,
est venu présenter
un burger dont il a concocté
la recette
et qui sera ajouté
pour quelques semaines à la carte.
-Je vais le manger
à la main. C'est un crash test
avec vous, on va voir.
Est-ce que j'en mets partout ?
Est-ce que c'est décadent ?
On espère.
-L'influenceur touchera 1 euro
par burger vendu.
Sa vidéo sera diffusée
en cross post,
c'est-à-dire en même temps
sur son compte
et sur celui du restaurant,
qui peut ainsi gagner des abonnés.
-Pour être connecté
avec la clientèle,
il faut être sur les réseaux.
Il faut offrir
ce que ta communauté
ou tes clients veulent
entendre.
-Le compte Instagram
de ce restaurant dépasse désormais
les 11 000 abonnés.
Son recours fréquent
à des influenceurs
n'y est pas pour rien.
-Vous, vous êtes
critique culinaire.
Il y a une différence
avec les influenceurs food ?
-Je crois que je suis devenue
influenceuse.
J'avais une carte de presse,
je l'ai rendue, et...
Il y a une différence.
On critique en positif
ou en négatif,
on dit si on a aimé
ou pas aimé.
François Simon,
à l'époque du Figaro,
c'était un critique
qui donnait son avis.
-Il le fait toujours.
-Tout à fait.
-Vous, c'est plutôt positif.
-C'est toujours positif.
On a fait une vidéo négative.
C'est 4 jours de travail
entre le tournage,
le montage, etc...
Est-ce qu'on passe 4 jours
pour dire : "N'y allez pas ?" Non.
Quand on n'aime pas,
on n'en parle pas.
Et de tempérament,
je suis plutôt joyeuse,
j'aime m'enthousiasmer.
Quand je n'aime pas,
je sais pas quoi dire.
On parle de ce qu'on aime.
-Mais les influenceurs,
on les voit, il y a du placement
de produits, de la pub.
C'est comme ça
qu'ils sont rémunérés.
Quel est votre modèle économique ?
-En fait,
on a les produits dérivés,
comme les revues, les livres.
On a des partenariats
avec les régions.
La ligne qu'on ne dépassera pas,
contrairement à l'influenceur,
c'est d'être payé par un restaurant.
Les restaurants nous demandent,
les grands groupes
en nous demandant
combien ça coûte.
-Vous refusez ?
-Vous payez votre repas ?
-Oui.
C'est pas grand-chose.
-Lui le fait pas.
-Et en plus,
on le paye pour faire ça.
-Mais il est transparent.
-Oui, oui.
Ca me pose pas de problème.
-Je sais pas
si le restaurant le paye.
-Il touche 1 euro...
-Ca, c'est le deuxième.
Pas le premier, Alexis.
-Il ne paye pas son menu,
mais il n'est pas rémunéré
-Vous êtes invitée,
parfois, non ?
Vous tenez forcément...
-Ils veulent nous inviter,
on refuse.
Cette règle,
on l'applique à tout le monde.
Parfois, il faut se battre
pour payer l'addition.
Et même quand ils veulent m'offrir
la moitié, je dis non.
A la fin,
on met le ticket de caisse.
Les gens voient
combien ça a coûté.
On m'offre le café, voilà.
-Vous, c'est les publicités
qui arrivent avant ou après
qui vous payent.
-Une vidéo à 40 millions de vues,
ça fait...
-Ca génère de la publicité.
-Meta vous reverse
parce qu'ils mettent
des publicités.
C'est une partie
de notre modèle économique.
On a des partenariats
avec les régions.
Je les ai contactées :
"Je peux mettre en avant
votre territoire."
Avec la Bretagne,
on a fait 7 vidéos, j'ai dit :
"Ne me dites pas où je vais.
"Je fais à ma manière."
Ils ont dit d'accord.
On a touché 10 millions
de personnes
sur cette campagne.
J'avais choisi les restaurants.
"Ca, ça me plaît pas."
-Vous choisissez.
-Oui. J'avais fait
un partenariat avec Lille
qui voulait des étoilés.
"Allez chercher les gens
qui font ça, mais pas moi.
"Moi, laissez-moi faire
à ma manière."
Ils ont accepté
et c'était formidable.
-Vous pourriez faire
de la publicité, comme Alexis,
avec un produit de marque
qu'on vous voit goûter ?
-Non, pour l'instant,
on a refusé.
Pour l'instant, non.
-Ca vous choque ?
-Je pourrais
pour des produits que j'aime.
Là, c'était
de l'agroalimentaire.
J'ai pas eu envie...
En fait, on m'a proposé
des publicités
pour des marques
qui me plaisaient pas,
-Et si la marque vous plaît ?
Plein de chefs font des pubs
pour des produits
qu'ils estiment sains.
-On le voit dans mes vidéos.
On fait des vidéos au restaurant,
mais aussi des recettes.
On l'a fait pour rire
mais ça a marché
et on fait les deux.
Smeg, la marque Smeg est
notre annonceur
et sponsorise toutes les vidéos.
C'est marqué,
il n'y a pas de...
J'ai une cuisine Smeg.
Parce que la marque me plaisait.
Je trouve ça très beau.
-Vous avez...
Conscience de l'influence
que vous pouvez avoir
pour faire et défaire
des notoriétés ? Ca vous...
Ca vous freine, parfois ?
C'est pas facile de dire
ce qu'on pense.
-Oui, mais moi,
je ne défais rien.
Si je faisais
de la critique négative,
ça pourrait être
problématique.
Quelqu'un qui travaille mal,
je veux pas vider son resto.
Il vit comme il en a envie
et c'est pas à moi de juger.
Etant donné que nous,
on conseille...
Récemment, on m'a invitée,
un journaliste m'a invitée
dans une crêperie
qui marchait pas très bien.
C'était excellent,
j'ai voulu faire une vidéo.
A présent, il y a tellement
d'affluence
qu'elle n'arrive plus à suivre
et elle n'ouvre que le midi.
-Et là, c'est quoi,
le secret pour faire
du clic ? Comment faire
de cette crêperie
un lieu hyper fréquenté ?
-On est suivis
par 2 millions de personnes
sur l'ensemble des réseaux,
donc...
-Ca crée une communauté ?
-Tout à fait. Et là,
récemment, on a filmé
dans le Cantal. On a posté la vidéo
il y a 15 jours.
J'ai eu un message du chef,
qui est plein à 15 jours.
Lui n'avait pas de problème
de fréquentation,
encore que la semaine, ça pouvait...
Moi, je suis ravie.
Il y a des restaurants,
sachant cette affluence,
qui ont refusé que je les filme.
"On pourra pas tenir."
Je trouve ça bien.
Ca sert à rien
s'ils refusent, après,
les appels.
-Comment vous analysez
cette passion
des réseaux pour la nourriture ?
De Jakarta à Angoulême en passant
par San Francisco et Moscou.
Comment vous l'analysez ?
-Ca prouve quand même...
Cette universalité,
ça prouve l'occidentalisation
du monde.
Ca passe par Instagram,
tous les réseaux sociaux.
Je pense que les gens
qui vivent encore
au fin fond de l'Amazonie,
ils ont pas cette...
-Tout le monde a un portable,
même très loin,
même reculé.
-Mais est-ce qu'ils filment ?
Alors, je sais pas pourquoi,
quand j'ai commencé l'ethnologie,
mes profs disaient :
"La cuisine, c'est important,
"mais il faudrait un sujet
"sérieux..."
On est dans une société
judéo-chrétienne.
Je disais que je comprenais.
J'ai pas regardé récemment
les travaux des ethnologues,
mais beaucoup doivent travailler
sur la cuisine.
Je sais pas l'analyser.
Il y a eu cette mondialisation,
cet engouement incroyable
que je sais pas analyser.
-Partout, on prend la photo du plat,
moi le premier.
J'ai honte de me dire : "Pourquoi
je prends ce plat en photo ?"
-C'est viral, en fait.
-Au départ, j'étais gênée,
je le faisais,
je me cachais un peu,
je trouvais ça affreux.
Maintenant, je suis décomplexée,
il faut que j'annonce.
-Il y a des chefs furieux.
-Oui, je comprends.
Il y a un restaurant
en Italie,
il y a des boîtes
où on met son portable
et on ferme à clef.
Respect, le chef est quand même
maître à bord.
-C'est son oeuvre.
-C'est un lieu privé,
il fait ce qu'il veut.
-Vous le disiez,
petite, vous mangiez
des cuisses de grenouilles.
Saviez-vous qu'elles venaient
de l'autre bout du monde ?
On en parle
et on met les pieds dans le plat.
-Vous le savez,
les Français ont la réputation
de "mangeurs de grenouilles",
réputation à peine exagérée,
car la France est
le premier importateur
de ces délicieux batraciens.
Derrière
la cuisse de grenouille
en persillade
se cache une réalité sombre
comme l'a montré une enquête
de l'ONG PETA,
qui lutte contre la maltraitance
animale.
C'est un reportage
de France Télévisions
avec Hélène Bonduelle
et Marion Devauchelle.
-C'est l'une des spécialités
de ce restaurant,
l'un des plats phares
de la gastronomie
française :
les cuisses de grenouilles.
-On les met dans la farine.
On fait chauffer
du beurre clarifié.
Ca, c'est de l'ail
qu'on a mixé.
Dernière étape,
un peu de persil.
-Une recette testée
souvent avec curiosité
par les touristes étrangers.
-Ca ne ressemble à rien
de ce que j'ai déjà mangé.
C'est unique comme goût.
-Unique et pourtant
pas si français que ça.
La quasi-totalité des cuisses
consommées en France
est importée,
principalement d'Indonésie,
premier exportateur mondial.
Des amphibiens
capturés dans la nature,
même si c'est interdit,
et dans des conditions d'abattage
dénoncées par cette association
de défense des animaux.
-On voit toutes les grenouilles
qui sont dans des sacs bondés,
les unes sur les autres.
Elles respirent par la peau.
Les unes sur les autres,
elles étouffent.
Des fois, elles restent
jusqu'à 2 jours dans ces sacs.
On leur coupe les pattes
vivantes.
Quand on leur coupe la tête,
si c'est mal fait,
elles respirent.
Là, on voit la grenouille
qui respire encore,
qui tremble
alors qu'on l'a à moitié décapitée.
C'est des animaux
qui sont sensibles,
qui ont un système nerveux,
qui ressentent la douleur.
-La branche Asie de l'association
a enquêté 3 ans
dans une dizaine
de centres d'abattage
à Java, Bali ou Sumatra.
-Les grenouilles
d'Indonésie,
c'est majoritairement
des grenouilles sauvages
qui sont capturées dans les marais,
dans la nature.
Les grenouilles sont des animaux
extrêmement importants
pour la biodiversité,
elles mangent les insectes.
S'il y a plus grenouilles,
il y a trop d'insectes,
on met des pesticides
et on s'empoisonne.
Donc en fait,
c'est ce qui s'est passé en Inde.
Les grenouilles qu'on consommait
en France venaient de France.
Ca posait problème,
on a interdit leur capture.
Ensuite, on est allé se servir
en Inde.
Il s'est passé la même chose
en Inde
donc on est allé en Indonésie.
Il est en train de se passer
la même chose.
Et l'étape suivante,
c'est la Turquie.
-Des étiquettes mensongères
sur l'origine
et les espèces de grenouilles,
des problèmes de traçabilité :
PETA France a enquêté auprès
de la grande distribution française.
Plusieurs distributeurs
ont depuis suspendu ou arrêté
leurs importations
depuis ces abattoirs indonésiens.
D'autres pas,
comme cette enseigne
spécialisée dans les surgelés.
-Dans le numéro 2
de votre revue,
la question à la une était :
"Faut-il mettre du sentiment
"dans nos assiettes ?"
Est-ce que vous allez en mettre
dans votre assiette
quand on va servir des grenouilles ?
-Oui, dans tous les cas,
il faut faire attention
à ce qu'on mange.
Juste un petit bémol,
j'ai beaucoup pêché la grenouille
quand j'étais en Dombes,
pour notre consommation,
on n'avait pas le droit
de les vendre.
Quand on apportait des grenouilles
à ma grand-mère,
elle coupait la tête comme ça.
-Comme les Indonésiens ?
-Les grenouilles continuent
à bouger
la tête coupée
parce que c'est
le côté nerveux.
-Parce que l'ONG explique
qu'ils les coupent mal,
ce qui ne les tue pas.
-Après, avec mon père,
on a commencé à trouver ça cruel,
donc on les assommait
avant de leur couper la tête.
On les mettait
dans des grands sacs
en toile de jute
qu'on appelait des troubles,
c'est un terme patois,
c'est comme ça...
Elles mordent, on ferre,
elles font un vol plané
et on les rattrape.
Il y a une dextérité.
Elles s'entassaient
dans un sac
mais au lieu de rester 2 jours,
elles restaient 3 heures.
Mais voilà,
c'est tuer un animal.
Oui, jamais je...
Je le dis, je mange de la viande,
je mange du poisson,
mais la souffrance animale est
un vrai sujet.
Je trouve ça grave.
Gandhi disait qu'on mesure le degré
de civilisation d'un peuple
à comment il traite ses animaux
et je crois que c'est vrai.
-Vous aviez connaissance
de la façon dont on les traite ?
-Non mais ça ne m'étonne
qu'à moitié. On a été
tellement loin dans l'horreur...
-C'est la faute de qui ?
De l'Indonésie
ou de ceux qui importent
comme nous ?
-Hé bien, les deux.
L'Indonésie devrait proposer
des grenouilles qui sont pêchées.
D'ailleurs, je croyais
que c'était en élevage.
-C'est compliqué,
les élevages,
elles se barrent
en sautant les barrières.
Ce sont des grenouilles pêchées
dans les étangs,
dans les lacs d'Indonésie,
de Sumatra à Bali.
-En plus, si ça met en péril
la biodiversité...
J'arrête de manger des avocats
car c'est très gourmand en eau
et qu'il y a des problèmes
avec les nappes phréatiques,
et c'est importé.
Je pourrais arrêter
de manger des grenouilles,
même si j'adore ça,
si elles sont pas...
-Il faudrait arrêter d'en importer
en France ?
-En tout cas, choisir
les bonnes filières.
Il doit y en avoir.
Quitte à ce que ça devienne
un produit de luxe,
vous voyez ? De toute manière,
il faut faire attention
à la filière,
qu'il y ait une transparence,
et savoir d'où ça vient,
comment c'est pêché,
comment c'est tué, transformé.
-On peut s'étonner
que le législateur
ne soit pas intervenu.
Les grandes marques,
de leur propre chef,
ne prennent plus...
-Il faut que la DGCCRF
jette un oeil.
-Ou qu'il y ait une loi
pour interdire d'importer
des grenouilles
tuées dans ces conditions.
-Il y a tromperie.
-Oui, elle le dit.
-Alors, après,
le reportage le dit, on est
un des plus gros importateurs
en Europe, c'est ça ?
Ou dans le monde ?
-Dans le monde.
-Premier importateur en France.
J'ai vu en France.
-La France ?
-On est le pays qui en importe
le plus.
On est des mangeurs
de grenouilles.
-On en mange tant que ça ?
Hors de la Dombes,
j'en mange jamais.
-En restaurant,
vous en voyez souvent ?
-Très rarement.
-On les refile sous le manteau ?
-Il y en a beaucoup
surgelées en supermarché.
-Il y a une grande enseigne
de surgelés qui...
-C'est pas très compliqué à faire.
-Autant l'escargot,
je le vois
à Paris ou ailleurs,
autant les grenouilles,
on en voit moins.
-En province.
Et les consommateurs les achètent
eux-mêmes.
Ces marques indonésiennes
sont destinées
à la grande distribution.
-J'ai jamais acheté
de grenouilles
parce que je les mange qu'en Dombes.
Et on avait même une expression
métonymique pour dire
"on va au restaurant", on disait :
"On va manger des grenouilles."
Parce qu'il y avait toujours
des grenouilles en entrée.
-Et vous en mangez
régulièrement ?
-Non,
je ne vais plus en Dombes,
donc ça fait plusieurs années.
Quand je suis allée tourner
à Lyon
dans un petit bistrot,
il y avait des grenouilles.
-A la carte.
-Je les aime là-bas
en persillade.
Je mangerai jamais
des grenouilles à Bordeaux.
Voilà.
-Alors, on a fini,
on va passer au dessert
et c'est le péché mignon
-Avec, Brigitte,
du régressif classique
qui sent bon le déjeuner familial,
une bonne mousse au chocolat.
Valeur sûre pour les gourmands
et culte pour les amateurs
ou les accros
à la tablette noire 70 %.
La petite histoire dit
que c'est le cuisinier suisse
Charles Fazi
qui a inventé
cette mousse au chocolat
pour notre roi Louis XVI.
Elle s'appelle d'abord mousse
de chocolat.
On se demande si la mousse
est extraite
d'un chocolat déjà chauffé.
C'est plutôt vers 1820
qu'elle devient une vraie recette
à base de chocolat, jaunes d'oeufs,
crème et sucre,
ce qui contribue
à populariser ce dessert.
On prête aussi
à Toulouse-Lautrec l'invention
de la recette comportant du cacao,
du blanc d'oeufs monté en neige
et du beurre.
Alors, quel est le secret
d'une bonne mousse au chocolat
du dimanche ?
-Pour la faire
ou quel goût elle doit avoir ?
-Pour la manger.
-J'aime quand elle est mousseuse
parce que parfois,
on a des mousses au chocolat...
-Il y a des textures
assez différentes.
-Elle peut être compacte.
-Elle est assez compacte.
-Non, ça va quand même !
Il ne faut pas que ce soit du vent.
Il faut quelque chose
en bouche.
-Je ne veux pas juger,
elle est bonne,
mais je la trouve plutôt
compacte.
-Je trouve que ça va,
ce degré de mousse
et de compact.
-Je la trouve un peu compacte.
-Vous aussi ?
-Un petit peu.
-Surtout,
elle est très chocolatée.
-Oui.
-Donc vous, vous aimez,
quand il y a 70 % de chocolat ?
-Oui,
avec peu de sucre,
un chocolat
qui a beaucoup de goût
et qui a une certaine amertume.
Je n'aime pas le sucre,
je ne mange jamais de dessert
sauf les desserts au chocolat,
le nec plus ultra étant
la mousse.
C'est pour ça
que je vous ai demandé...
-Il doit y avoir les jaunes,
pour qu'elle soit un peu
compacte ?
-C'est pas impossible.
Ou alors un peu de crème
ou du beurre.
Et ce que j'aime bien...
-Vous mettez la crème
et du beurre dedans ?
-J'en mets un peu partout.
Il m'arrive parfois d'en mettre.
Ce que j'aime beaucoup,
c'est les petits copeaux.
Ce qui compte dans un dessert,
c'est les textures.
Je trouve que vous êtes durs
avec cette mousse.
-Je la trouve très bonne,
très chocolatée.
Si on doit la dire
compacte ou légère,
je la trouve plutôt compacte.
-Oui mais un bon degré.
-Vous l'aimez améliorée
avec des petites...
-Oui.
J'aime pas avec des fruits
ou de l'alcool, voilà,
j'aime le chocolat pur et dur.
Le chocolat,
j'en mange toute la journée.
-Toute la journée ?
Sous forme de tablette, au bureau ?
-Ouais, ouais.
Mes collègues le savent,
ils viennent m'en piquer.
Et je ne peux pas me passer
de chocolat.
-On commence à quoi, 70 % ?
-Oui, et je ne vais pas
à plus de 75 %
parce qu'en fait,
je trouve que c'est le bon...
Stéphane Bonnat,
un chocolatier
avec qui j'ai voyagé,
qui est vraiment passionné,
il va chercher des crus
et il conche... C'est la chose
la plus importante.
Il y a peut-être 6 chocolatiers...
Le conchage,
c'est la transformation,
une étape de la transformation
et qui va donner cette texture.
Ce qui est bon
dans le chocolat...
Il y a eu une mode du chocolat,
des gens
qui ont fait ce qu'on appelle
le "bean to bar", de la fève
jusqu'à la tablette,
mais il leur manque l'étape
qui fait qu'il y a quelque chose
de soyeux en bouche.
Et donc,
pourquoi je vous disais ça ?
Je me suis perdue.
Oui, 75 %, pour moi,
c'est l'équilibre.
-Entre l'amertume et le sucré.
-A 90 %,
c'est pas intéressant,
il y a un côté rugueux en bouche.
Et moins, il n'y a pas assez
de chocolat.
75 %, c'est bien.
-Et sinon, jamais de dessert ?
-Non, je n'aime pas trop.
J'y arrive
mais le sucre est un problème
pour moi.
J'aime pas le goût sucré,
sauf le chocolat.
-Quand on goûte,
quand on va au restaurant,
difficile pour vous de juger
les desserts ?
-J'ai de la chance,
il y a très souvent
des desserts au chocolat
dans les restaurants.
Je sais plus qui disait
que 9 Français sur 10 aiment
le chocolat
et le dixième qui dit
ne pas aimer, il ment.
Je crois que tout le monde
aime le chocolat.
Quand il y en a pas,
je tente quelque chose.
J'ai du mal
avec le sucre depuis enfant,
j'ai jamais mangé
très sucré.
-Comment vous jugez
ces pâtisseries
de plus en plus sophistiquées ?
Ces pâtissiers, pâtissières,
comme Nina Métayer,
de plus en plus médiatiques,
qui sont des stars maintenant
et qui ne font plus des gâteaux
mais des oeuvres d'art.
Est-ce que ça vous impressionne ?
C'est une bonne chose
pour la pâtisserie
ou au contraire,
on change de registre ?
On n'ose même plus les manger.
-Cédric Grolet avait fait
un Rubik's Cube.
Je sais que je l'aimerais pas,
je l'ai jamais mangé,
mais j'adorais croquer.
Je le trouve beau, appétissant.
Je trouve ça
fascinant d'arriver,
on est
dans la maîtrise du sucre,
d'arriver à faire quelque chose
qui ressemble aussi...
De façon aussi fidèle
à la chose qui est représentée.
Ca peut être des fruits...
Moi, ça m'attire pas
gustativement,
mais je trouve que c'est un peu
comme Antonin Carême
qui faisait, au XIXe,
des plats tout en hauteur.
Ca s'inscrit dans l'histoire
de la cuisine française.
C'est un moment important
et qu'on peut analyser.
-Il y a une tendance
vers des desserts
avec très peu de sucre.
Des chefs proposent
des desserts à peine sucrés.
-Je trouve ça super. Moi,
moins c'est sucré,
plus je peux les manger.
-Je pensais à vous.
-Quand je mange,
dans des maisons d'hôtes,
des desserts de grand-mère,
souvent, c'est très peu sucré.
Il y a eu une dérive
où on s'est mis à sucrer
car les gens aiment ça.
Ce que j'aime
chez des pâtissiers,
c'est qu'ils se remettent
aux fruits de saison.
Vous avez des tartes aux fraises
ou aux framboises toute l'année
dans plein de pâtisseries.
Il y a une mouvance
qui respecte les saisons.
Pourquoi on respecte pas
aussi les saisons
pour les tartes aux fruits ?
L'hiver, la tarte aux pommes,
c'est bien.
-Ce sont des fruits congelés.
Quand on va au ski et qu'on mange
une tarte aux myrtilles
avec 2 mètres de neige,
on se dit que...
-Si c'est de la cueillette
et qu'on congèle, pourquoi pas.
-Mais c'est pas forcément
des fraises du Chili.
-Ah oui, oh...
En pâtisserie...
Mais quand on va à la montagne,
vous avez raison.
notre invitation.
Merci à vous tous
de nous avoir suivis.